all right so we have a new sponsor on
the show we don't usually start off with
an ad but I'm kind of very excited about
this
we got the sponsorship late last night I
am a big fan of the the natural world
Ben knows this I love I love nature I
love to swim
I love pools but even more importantly I
love lakes and I love oceans these are
things that I am invested in and I mean
I've never been a hysterical Obul
warming on either side
climate change is probably real you know
and and and maybe we could do something
positive about it I don't know but I
love swimming I grew up around the ocean
and I grew up swimming as a kid with my
mother these are the things always
remember about my childhood the smell of
salt water and the sand under your feet
running around I mean this is so when
when we destroy the oceans we're
destroying not only are our habitats or
destroying all these great experiences
so we're very happy to kind of wear this
new project that we're backing right now
and we're trying to involve a lot of our
people in it as well and just a few
minutes of it to just kind of tell you
what it what it's about the weather is
very very important to us it actually
affects every single aspect of our lives
she's right before I came to Iceland I
checked the weather I'm super happy that
I did my umbrella was handy last night
I'm sure it was for many of you
farmers are it's essential for farming
when to plant the crops when to take and
when to harvest the crops so I'm
delighted today for the first time to be
able to have the Weather Channel have a
look at what's happening for the first
time in history actually in the high
seas thank you so much Gillian and we've
got wonderful new technology here at the
Weather Channel and we are able to
deliver a point forecast for the Arctic
high season we'll take one location that
is north of the northernmost part of
Canada near the Mian Islands and as you
might expect it's going to be very
chilly indeed here temperatures will for
the most part only get up into the
negative 20s Celsius through the entire
week so you want to take an extra pair
of knickers should you be here anytime
soon and we'll take you to another spot
on the other side of the Arctic
and that is north of Russia northeast of
the Anzu Islands and similarly it's
going to be quite cold temperatures in
the negative numbers all across the
board right through the end of the week
getting a little bit warmer going into
Thursday Friday and Saturday now back to
you in Iceland thank you
that's clever because what she did I
don't know this woman is what she's
doing is she's trying to get people into
supporting the oceans but she's using
things they know like The Weather
Channel I I like this a lot
I don't know she is but she's got a
bright future well today because that is
a first for the Arctic it is a first for
the high seas and it's a first for the
Weather Channel so what's this focus on
the weather it's really exciting of
course that now for the first time in
history we have the weather for the high
seas in the Arctic that's about 1% of
the high seas in total but what that
really means is that almost half the
planet we have no weather for think
about that for a second flag raised
almost half the fact that we don't have
full and full data for the wedges
girlfriends reusable and our friends
from the fisheries data is especially
isn't it and a turkey so it's exciting
that is I just want to talk a little bit
about exploration so I spend I like
going budget is about 250 times more
than my life what does your dish budget
bringing it and some of the reasons for
the holes in our ocean exploration to
put this into perspective on the right
hand side that's a picture of James
Cameron going down to the bottom of the
ocean at about 36,000 feet people in the
history of our planet have ever gone
down to the bottom of the ocean by
contrast the very good-looking chap on
the left is our space moon Walker and
we've had 12 who have walked on the moon
she makes it fun which I like because
you want the environment should be fun
oh she seems unfocused here a little bit
but her style is to just be in an hour
I don't really know what's going on but
I think it's good but just to put that
into perspective fee winning me over map
the moon to about seven between seven
meters and a hundred meters which is
crazy when you think of that nuts and
also what's odd is that since in the
last forty years since we've been to the
moon we've brought back about 850 pounds
of moon rocks again by contrast we take
out between a hundred and about a
hundred and thirty billion worth of fish
tons of fish a year now the variable as
many of you will know is because we
don't really know what what the value is
on the illegal fishing department
because boats as we know not all boats
attract there are about illegal food
sovereignty of people have no idea how
much your problem illegal fishing is
it's one of the biggest problems in the
country in the world is illegal fishing
people fishing when they shouldn't
without a permit and stuff so much if it
goes on and and and it's I don't know
this woman
but detect it she has the guts and the
balls to kind of call out the illegal
fishermen to me he's huge let's let's
let it go for another few minutes
it's that attract for instance in the
high seas and just I would like you to
think about this for a second okay
I'd like to know how many of you would
like to fly on a plane if only 15
percent of planes were talking to air
traffic control I don't want it I don't
want to again a little bit more
comfortable here in Iceland if only
fifteen percent of the drivers Rose had
license plates no good we all know I
mean I'm I'm a bit of a speed demon so I
go through those red lights as I knew
that no one was tracking me but it
allows them to fish for endangered
species but use a drone and kill them
chances that they'll be captured capture
them madly less and so that's a problem
because it's putting alright well anyway
the Terramar project is what we're we've
just entered into a partnership with on
this show it's called the Terramar
project I don't know what that means I
think water and land or something and
and both are very necessary and this
this woman is [ __ ] bright and I don't
know who she is but I like I like the
cut of her jib and I just enjoy it and
so if you like me think illegal fishing
is the biggest problem in America and
the world you will get involved with
this Terramar project to really kind of
[ __ ] go and get those illegal boats
because we need to know who's fishing
that's the biggest issue that's the
biggest issue on the on the high seas
right now on the water
who is fishing where they shouldn't be
fishing so if there's any way that we
can find those people I think so many
other problems are are linked into this
illegal fishing it almost seems like
illegal fishing is the way that the
world is run you see there's all these
fishermen fishing illegally for fish
that they shouldn't have that they
should have thrown back into the water
and one fisherman knows that the other
fisherman is doing this with the illegal
fish he doesn't know and so there's this
weird
omerta like silence around the idea of
illegal fishing none of the illegal
fishermen tell on any of the other
illegal fishermen and nobody has a
[ __ ] license everybody just says
we're just going out for a fun you know
yacht day but it's not they're illegally
fishing taking fish they shouldn't have
and doing god only knows what to it on a
boat and they all have each other's back
and it's a code of silence and they
bribe each other and they blackmail each
other with these illegal fish and this
woman has the balls to call it out I
don't know how he pronounced your name
just something but god bless her and God
bless the Terramar project Whitney
coming right up all right returning
favorite Whitney Webb back on the show
she is a writer her articles appear at
the last American vagabond amongst other
publications she has a patreon that you
should support we're gonna put the link
in the description of this episode and I
believe she is in the process of writing
a book on the topic that we are going to
discuss today so Whitney Webb thank you
for coming back you're a fan favorite
here you were tweeting that you don't
buy the just lane arrest or you think
it's a little convenient a little suss
which means suspect as people on the
internet say what what about it strikes
you as as fishy all right where to start
first of all just before d'Alene was
arrested Virginia Roberts attorneys were
ordered by a US federal judge to destroy
evidence that pertain directly to
d'Alene Maxwell claiming that they had
obtained that evidence illegally and
thus it has to be destroyed and then
they arrest her like the next day right
what evidence
um it was evidence well it hasn't been
made public right but they claimed that
it had been sealed evidence apparently
acquired through some sort of FBI stuff
that was never made public and never
turned into an indictment right and Alan
Dershowitz was actually suing to try and
get access to that information and was
also denied access to it right so even
people that are you know representing
the victims and people that were
associates of eff seen have been denied
access to this but the lawyers who
obtained it we're trying to use it in
court and they said now you can't have
this and you have to destroy it and then
galina's you know arrest in a day later
in New Hampshire but um you know that's
just like one thing that preceded this
there's a couple other things that are
interesting that preceded this too but
um you know just to start off I think
it's it's good to start with just
talking about the indictment itself
which I really recommend people that are
interested in this piece actually take
the time to read the indictment against
Maxwell it's only like 18 pages so it's
not very long and that for me is the
main basis of why I am very suspect of
what is going on here what they charge
her like they charged her with I think
it's four counts one of them is perjury
the other three only relates to enticing
minors to travel across state lines for
the purpose of engaging in illegal sex
acts with Jeffrey Epstein
but the indictment itself says that the
Layne Maxwell was also involved in those
sex acts and is basically you know
basically saying that she sexually
assaulted these minors also but she's
not charged for that she's charged with
enticing three girls between 1994 in
1997 to travel across state lines to
engage in sex acts with Jeffrey Epstein
in which she was also involved and the
indictment even says things like it was
ghilane that ordered these girls to take
off their clothes and to touch Epstein
and that she would also become involved
and like you know a threesome or
something but she's not charged with
anything related to that right what's
just just like yes admit that and then
be like well you know it's fine that
you're a pedophile but you made them
travel for it right right so why are
they not charging her with the actual
molestation you know that's an
interesting you know I think that's a
very valid point in a question that
should be asked of the people you know
the FBI and the Southern District in New
York and you know you know the people
responsible for this indictment also as
far as her arrest where is her mugshot
right why hasn't she appeared in federal
court yet she was supposed to be
arraigned yesterday there's been no news
on that about her having appeared in
court right that's not normal does
debris act at a mug shot right now if
she was charged with actually molesting
the girls would that carry a longer
sentence oh for sure and it would also
mean that she could be denied bail based
on the types of charges she's facing out
it's very likely she'll be allowed to
post bail and won't go to prison unless
she is sentenced at the conclusion of
the trial right so who knows what could
happen by them whenever that happens it
could be a protracted legal process
they've also set up the
narrative that villains going to
cooperate with authorities which you
know when that happens results in a
reduced sentence so it's I think it's
very likely based on the charges she's
facing which are extremely light when
you consider the gravity of her crimes
how many children she raped how many
children she recruited for Epstein you
know among numerous other things she was
involved in I mean cuz this wasn't just
three girls like she was she's been
charged with enticing to travel now I
mean this network in which the lane was
you know basically the key one of the
the key people if not the key person of
used thousands of girls right right
right now she's arrested she's taken to
where where is she is she is she gonna
go to the same facility the cheff was in
like where well no we don't know it
appeared in federal court well at the
time of us recording this right right
she has been made to appear there's no
mugshot of her no one really knows it
was just reported that she was arrested
and then they had this press conference
arm but they didn't show a mug shot or
anything they just showed a picture of
you know ghilane and Jeffrey I've seen
together from 2005 and they just talked
about how great they are for having
arrested her even though they apparently
have known where she is for a year
because the hell she was arrested in a
New Hampshire she bought seven months
ago right now wasn't there an article
that came out a while back that said she
was staying in either Massachusetts or
New Hampshire I forget what was that
article and it was saying she was
staying with a guy right somebody hell
yeah his name is Scott Borgess and he's
alleged to be her current boyfriend he
runs a company that's a data analytics
company for like ocean freight which is
interesting when you considered Elaine's
recent interest in this whole Terramar
project of creating sort of this these
independent state lakes I guess you
could say in the ocean where
international law would it apply right
but I mean in her in her defense there's
a lot of good people involved in that
too like Bill glades and the Clintons
right right yeah
but anyway so this guy right on his
company the main investor in it is Eric
Schmidt the former Google had ahead of
Google right who's also tied up with the
Clintons and all of these fun guys
yeah so that's who she was said to have
been staying with and what's interesting
is after that report came out right
after that is when the fake in-and-out
burger picture photo op or whatever in
LA came out basically making people
think that she was actually on the west
coast which I guess now in a retrospect
was a way to divert attention from what
was actually happening what was the
point of doing that in-and-out photo
shoot I never understood that they
photoshopped a movie advertisement in
the background like it was one of the
weirdest pieces of political theater if
you want to say his political it was
this stunt what in your estimation was
the point of that well I think there's a
couple of well first of all was
orchestrated by her attorney and also
let's remember the book she was reading
the life and death of CIA operatives or
something like that and considering the
whole intelligence ties of this and also
Blaine's face in the picture I mean she
looks ridiculously smug and she's just
sitting there in public I mean I think
it was honestly sort of the way like you
know to slap everyone in the face and be
like you know you can't [ __ ] with me
type of deal I think it was something
like that and you know it really started
this whole trend of media reporting to
UM ghilane that treated her like she was
Carmen Sandiego
oh she's you know in LA now she's in
France now she's in England now she's in
Israel right about all this stuff where
is she right making Noah acting like you
know implying that she was just
traveling all the time so maybe that's
why they couldn't find her right when in
fact she's been in the u.s. the whole
time and they've known it and haven't
done [ __ ] right why do you think if they
waited to arrest her what do you think
that was about do you think they were
waiting for the conditions to be because
bar the Attorney General is this is not
a person who's interested in getting to
the bottom of this case right right I
mean Attorney General Bill Barr
his father was the the headmaster of
Dalton who hired Jeffrey Epstein so he
was also an intelligence bill Barr was
services the precursor to the CIA and at
the time he hired Epstein his son Bill
Maher was working at the CIA remember
that's where Bill Maher's career started
he worked for the CIA right so we have
to believe that this attorney general
has been intelligence his entire life
whose father is intelligence whose
father hired abstain wants to get to the
bottom of this story right right well I
could also look at Bill bars like past
right he helped cover up iran-contra
pardon all the iran-contra criminals
when he was Attorney General the first
time under george bush senior also a CIA
director right and helped cover up the
promise software scandal in which the
Maxwell family was very intimately
involved right so like not exactly who
finds things out he's more of a guy who
covers things up if you look at his you
know track record he also worked at the
law firm that was you know offered where
the defense lawyers for Jeffrey Epstein
when he was arrested the first time so
bill Barr was working at the law firm of
of Jeffrey Epstein's defense attorneys
the first time Epstein was arrested
interested in what capacity just as an
attorney or a consultant or I believe he
was an attorney I'm the law firm is
Kirkland and Ellis I believe yeah but
that's where like his defense lawyers
were also part of that firm but I mean
it's not like Barr was part of Epstein's
legal team but he was you know in the
same law firm is is there any truth to
the what's being circulated on Twitter
that bill Barr wanted to meet ghilane
Maxwell just Lane Maxwell and her
attorney denied that or is that just
floating around on Twitter this kind of
unsubstantiated
I heard that so I can't really speak to
that but what's interesting though is
that about less than two weeks ago bill
Barr made this big there was this
controversy in this very district we're
talking about right the Southern
District of New York where Jeffrey
Berman who was the district attorney
when Epstein was indicted last year was
basically forced out and so the person
that is currently the district attorney
isn't official they're an acting
district attorney and Berman was you
know just removed from that capacity
essentially by bill bar around ten or
eleven days ago
and then you know this other judge you
know also part of the DOJ technically
right orders this evidence to be
destroyed and the billion is arrested
why was Berman forced out is there an
official story for that um well I
actually don't really know the official
story because I remember reading it
being like this was probably [ __ ]
right yeah um but I guess we're pointing
out that I don't think Jeffery Berman is
a clean guy right on he used to work for
Giuliani who's like a really shady guy
too and a lot of this stuff you know
there's just different factions you know
different I guess you could say
competing like crime families or
whatever you know and so like some of
them are dirty well they're all really
dirty but they have like you know
competing interests but I think it's
interesting the timing and I guess we
can speculate as to why it really was
right considering what's happened in the
days since no I think it's possible you
know for example that Bill Maher may not
have wanted going to be arrested at all
for example because he you know as you
pointed out right has some sort of
family tie to this case right yeah it's
possible that they didn't want this to
move forward at all even though in my
opinion the charges are a complete
freakin joke and are just gonna mean
that she you know gets off flight or you
know probably doesn't go to prison at
all if she cooperates or they settle or
who knows what what would be this the
fact I'm sorry no wolverson of
cooperating like what yeah yeah you know
it remains to be seen right but
basically you know even if she does give
them information they want on certain
people or you know things like that I
mean that's not gonna be made public
right so sound it's very possible that
she enters into some agreement where she
cooperates and supposedly gives them
information but none of that has ever
made public they have to decide what to
do with the nature of the trial but it's
very unlikely that it would be made
public and they could say it's for a
separate investigation that's classified
in who knows right right Ridge well it
um how many times do we have to tell you
[ __ ] people about Ridge wallet okay
this is the wallet of the future the
easiest wall to
ties the easiest wallet to hide okay
people won't even know you have it on
you it's a minimal small sleek front
facing front pocket wallet okay
thirty thousand five star reviews better
way to carry your cash and cards easy to
sanitize rub some hand sanitizer on your
hands throughout the ridge wallet in
there and you're safe baby it's easy
it comes in titanium carbon fiber
aluminum and over a dozen different
styles and colors okay get 10% off today
free worldwide shipping in Returns Ridge
calm /t I am that's rich calm /t I am
link in description I use it been uses
it we love this wallet it is a fantastic
wallet especially for the times that we
are living in where there is so much
uncertainty so much uncertainty chaos to
be exact and the ridge wallet provides a
sense of calm and stability even as you
are being beaten by protesters or police
whichever side of the line the divide
you find yourself on as they are beating
you mercilessly because you were the
avatar assistan that is oppressive and
unfair you will still find comfort in
the fact that your Ridge wallet knows
how to take the beating because it is a
tough titanium wallet okay and you're
going to be able to after the beating
you're gonna be able to call the cab ooh
BRR whatever you're gonna be able to pay
for it because they probably will not
have gotten your Ridge while your Ridge
wal can easily fit in your rectum it can
easily fit under an armpit it can fit in
a fold of fat you can you can even you
know show you a ridge wallet into your
skin which is I'm sure that before Bill
Gates does it why don't you do it first
the ridge wallet can be hidden you can
put it in your shoe between your toes it
is easy you could tuck if you tuck your
penis back to appear to be a female you
can tuck the ridge wallet under your
penal organ as well this is something
that a lot of people don't know about
the ridge wallet but it is it is not
flexible because it's metal but it is so
sleek it's just so easy to hide you know
it's so important right now you don't
want to advertise
you got cats you don't want a wallet
bulge if you want a bulge you know where
you want it but you don't want it in
your wallet because people say hey that
guy asks money I want that guy's money
let's kill that person because that's
where we're headed to people gonna just
see you well go that guy might have
money let's kill him let's take his
money and let's get Little Caesars or
something you know I don't know what
these people do but I'm just telling you
that's where we're at now because no one
has any money and they're gonna look at
you and if you appear to even have money
it's a problem so really the ridge
wallet is a great way to disguise the
fact that you even have a wallet on you
in the first place
this is not the time to be you know
brash it's not time to be making it rain
with the cash out there okay because
people are going to let your body on
fire and use it to warm their hands so
that's why it's so important to have a
diminutive wallet that you barely exists
you barely know it's there it's just a
couple of credit cards a little bit of
cash nothing really it's simple it's
very very easy you stay organized you
know where everything is and the most
important right now it's easily hidden I
mean this is really the selling point of
this it is easily hidden from the people
that will take it from you which will be
or your own family soon you know because
we're seeing you know this effective
from people in different ways in your
own family and community will rise up
against you eventually and try to take
what is yours you know and whether you
earned it or not it's yours at the
moment but they're coming for and
they're going to strip it from you
they're going to they're going to take
you I mean the only two skin graft to
put back what these people will take
from you I mean this is the truth I mean
truly that's why you should arm yourself
to the teeth I mean I'm not even timing
bazookas you know like military-grade
weaponry you know maybe maybe get a kind
of a disaster car that you could just
kind of you know fix you know put it put
a kind of a rocket launcher on top just
so that you can kind of ride around town
in style and also intimidate people that
are trying to kill you at any given
moment so Ridge wallet complex Tim ti M
if you use the code Tim link in
description you could 10% off they'll
ship it anywhere in the world they don't
care you're in Syria I'll give it to you
so god damn rich wallet you need it it's
it's it's it's the way to Stace
it's just a way to stay safe somebody
asks you think I hate every wallet on
you go no no I don't carry one I don't
carry a wallet it's easy because even
your best friend sooner or later because
how bad things are getting they'll go
hey every wallet on you if you go yeah
they'll turn around and put on I don't
stab me this route and just take it from
you could be your own father hey you
have a wallet on you yeah a dad I do
good hold on stun gun comes out he stuns
you you laying on the floor the house
you grew up in and your father and your
mother walk out with your wallet those
boomers don't give a [ __ ] Ridge comm /mt
IM promo code Tim Lincoln description be
safe be smart be Ridge anvil rings makes
awesome homemade jewelry in western
Colorado there's a man there who's in
the middle of a canyon in Colorado and
he's making rings out of the following
unique materials meteorite whiskey
barrel iron wood natural shed elk and
deer antler titanium and tungsten
carbide Damascus steel black and
acid-washed and many more the rings are
dreamt up made and assembled in the USA
there's over five hundred five star
reviews and every single purchase
includes a free anvil ring silicone
activity band and an anvil rings faux
leather ring box which is very nice this
is a great way to get a ring for
somebody that you care about
to commemorate something you may not
have the money to you know buy something
that is more expensive you know you
don't want to spend thousands you want
to spend hundreds but you want to get
something truly unique truly cool this
is handmade artisan jewelry being made
by a man in western Colorado on the FBI
watch list and it's so important that
he's able to kind of make these things
for you because god only knows what he'd
be doing this is his passion is making
rings he could be in a militia but he
does it he makes rings that's what's so
important he's channeling all of his
energy into something nice like making a
nice whiskey barrel ring for you okay
you know that's so important you know
he's not a violent separatist amassing
weaponry and getting ready for the
coming Civil War he's making nice
jewelry for you to give your lover after
you've had a lovely outside socially
distance date at Chili's
that's what it comes down to okay they
offer free sizers discounted after a
ring purchase during this time to stay
safe get sized at home so you don't need
to guesstimate the size of your finger
they will they will let you know so
whether you want a wedding band an
anniversary band or you just want a ring
that looks awesome head over to anvil
rings calm and use promo code Tim this
guy is great I don't know know who he is
but he's a fan of the show I picture
he's eka he's got like a beard and he
you know he lives and like some type of
Shaq you know but he's got a really nice
studio where he he makes the Rings cuz
that's his most important thing you know
you're helping a man live by ordering
one of these rings and and and and most
of the time he just you know I would
imagine he eats canned food and sits on
a cot you know but but then when a ring
order comes in his eyes light up and he
goes out and he drinks moonshine and
then by the moonlight he smites a ring
is that what you do see you smite it I
think so yeah you see smites a beautiful
ring and then he sends it off to someone
in st. Louis so they can give it to
someone else that's what's really
important and he just waits for these
ring orders to come in he waits and
waits and waits and just sit on the edge
of that bed and he's got a raggedy old
blanket it's all burned from you know
god only knows he's lit himself on fire
several times he doesn't he doesn't mean
to but this is probably what happens you
know he has flashbacks of Vietnam even
though he never served but it's so
important that you guys give this man
work no I mean truly I mean this is a
this is a child of God out there in
Colorado in western Colorado in a canyon
living in some type of shanty and he
wants to work for you he wants to make
nice rings for you you know he probably
doesn't own any clothing he just walks
around if you bumped into him in the
woods you would run away screaming and
I'm sure many hipsters do these little
pieces of [ __ ] that go out for a day
hike or whatever and then you bump into
him a real American at rupert's and you
know a man who's you know doesn't have
any finger prints cuz he burned them off
and you know a guy that really just you
know you know he's not on the grid he's
out there and you know the hipster kids
bump in home and they start screaming
and run away but all he wants to do is
make them rings to take back to their
speak
Easy's he just wants to make them rings
to take back to their little bars in
Williamsburg and because they're
cool-looking and they think rings just
happen they don't happen
an old warlock of a man makes them in
Colorado and that's why we're so happy
to partner with him because he shares so
many of our values and we really want
you to buy the Rings I mean helps the
show sure but it helps us out we're
getting rings we have rings on the way
yes and we're gonna wear them we can
start wearing them but this is a great
way and all seriousness I am serious
about everything I've said thus far but
in all seriousness it's a great way to
get a wedding band Engagement band
anniversary a ring that looks awesome
I mean it's just easy it's something
nice to do you want to get your dad or
mom or brother assist or something your
best friend your fiance this is a great
way to spend hundreds of dollars and
they're gonna it looks so much more
expensive than it is it looks so much
more expensive than it is okay and it's
so easy you don't have to go to Colorado
and try to find this guy in a canyon
okay you don't have to go find you know
the dilapidated fan he lives in in the
middle of a brush clearing you don't
have to do that you can easily go to
anvil rings com that's a NV IL RI ng s
calm and use promo code Tim to get 20%
off anvil rings dot-com promo code Tim
to get 20% off a ring do it right now
send me a photo of the ring that you got
we'll post it on our social media and
we'll tell you you're a good person and
and and then just like I saved the
children ad we will update you that will
show you know how to save the children
ads like hey your money went to buy
grain for the child or whatever it is we
will show you our automatic weapon that
this gentleman purchased with your ring
with the money you pay for the ring so
that is an bell rings com promo code Tim
TI m 20% off now for people that don't
know who dis lane maxwell is give us a
little background because you've really
done some work on most people know that
her father was a media mogul who had
intelligence ties to the Mossad but
you've really done a deep dive on the
family
talk a little bit about these fun folks
all right well there are a lot of places
we could go with that because it is
really extensive I mean Robert Maxwell
did not just have links or ties to
Israeli intelligence I mean he was a spy
period right he was involved with Israel
before it was even founded he was
involved in getting for example the the
Czech Republic to send weapons designers
paramilitaries before the founding of
the State of Israel
so his involvement in airplane parts and
things like that's having those smuggled
in he was very involved with that whole
you know a pre existence of the State of
Israel conflict right and that continued
well after I mean let's remember too
that Robert Maxwell's people was
attended by six former and current heads
of Israeli intelligence the person that
gave the eulogy was prime minister at
the time
it's hochche amir who said robert
maxwell has done more for israel that i
can say today and things like that right
so it's not just like the guy had
incidental links to israel he was also
it just involved in a ton of well-known
you know israeli espionage activities
including the promis software scandal
iran-contra the honeypot entrapment of
Israeli nuclear weapons whistleblower
Mordechai Vanunu among numerous others
right well go to the promised software
just out of curiosity you've mentioned
that before what was that so um it's
kind of a really compliments a very
complex case right um but to give like a
brief summary it was basically the
software that was developed by the Bill
and Nancy Hamilton of insula Inc it was
they originally sold it and at least it
essentially to the Department of Justice
under Reagan in like 1982 at which point
the Department of Justice basically
threw ed meese and this other guy that
was sort of in the Reagan administration
orbit named Earl Bryan basically made
plans with this guy who was in those
very famous Israeli intelligence
operative named Rafi a 10-2 essentially
steal this software by basically taking
it and not paying making payments to
inslaw for its use anymore and then
adapt
by asserting a backdoor into that
software which was then sold to
governments intelligence agencies and
corporations and banks all over the
world not just by people like Earl Bryan
and he was just mentioned he made you
know a company specifically for selling
software but Robert Maxwell had a Mossad
tech front company called Deng um that
he used to sell that software not just
you know throughout the Middle East but
also in the America of Central and South
America Robert Maxwell also sold it to
sensitive US National Laboratories in
New Mexico that were used to allow
Israel to gain access to that at a time
when they were spying heavily on us like
scientific and technological research
partner which is related with their
nuclear weapons program he also sold it
to Russian intelligence to the KGB so
Robert Maxwell was very involved but
also involved were people in the Clinton
orbit including Jackson Stevens company
who was a major you know political donor
to the Clintons systematics was the
company through which they did that
right which had ties to Rose Law Firm
which was Hillary Clinton's law firm at
the time and Vince Foster and all of
that so when you took about a backdoor
the intelligent the the software had a
back door the back door would be used to
extract information frying so yeah so
basically any computer in which the
software would installed that backdoor
would allow Israeli intelligence access
to whatever was on that computer so this
was an act of over an espionage well
covert oh oh yeah yeah right but I mean
people in the US knew the backdoor was
there because they helped sell it and
they knew Israel had access to it so
they essentially allowed Israel's
intelligence access no you know to
computers on sensitive us databases for
example right but also in other
countries you know but I mean that's
kind of treasonous isn't it
especially if you're in the Reagan
administration certainly yeah and Robert
Maxwell also was a major media mogul in
the UK and he owned was it six
newspapers I forget he owned a lot of
right he was also a media mogul on
Israel and set up newspapers there that
still exists today he also at one
my own in New York Daily News oh he's
trying to yes he was trying to expand at
the television it's at one point but
unsuccessfully he hated Rupert Murdoch
user in jealous of him and wanted to be
like Rupert Murdoch and have this TV
empire but it's funny we just we just
keep hearing like planes or motorcycles
I love I love every time you're on the
show you're in like a safe house
somewhere and I just don't know what's
happening
like I just I just imagine people are
loading planes and then right after this
interview is done you leave and then a
drone strike just destroys whatever and
then you just get on a plane somewhere
and garment submit we do hear a lot more
exciting it's just funny like like all
we hear like you're like talking about
promise software and in the back we like
get out get out so max well obviously
the guy is a spies an Israeli spy
there's a lot of Israeli spies but this
guy assimilates into British high
society yeah and he becomes you know the
Mossad is one of the the most successful
intelligence agencies in the world and
and they've you know I think the
minister of Syrian defense at one time
was a Mossad agent like they really
infiltrate places they're very good at
it and and so four Maxwell's entire
career he he's do and Seymour Hersh I
think wrote a wrote a book about him
about his activities too it was
mentioned in the Samson option which is
about Israel's nuclear weapons program
and that directly discussed Maxwell's
involvement and the arrest of the
whistleblower about Israel's nuclear
weapons program Mordechai Vanunu right
so I mean this isn't a conspiracy theory
this is you know as factual as you get
horrors children right well it depends
on which one you want to start with
right but what's interesting I think
arguably the most important argue lines
twin sisters Chris
Isabelle who get very little attention
but really quickly we are there where
are their are they on tick-tock no one
of them I think now teaches at the
University of Texas another one I'm not
exactly sure what she's doing now
because a lot of what I've looked at are
their involvement in the tech industry
because one of them Kristine in
particular was involved with a very very
shady software program counterterrorism
program that was put on the databases of
the CIA the FBI the NSA and a bunch of
other sensitive databases for US
intelligence in the u.s. national
security and her father of course was
the promis software salesman and
apparently no one saw any problems with
that right we can get into that I guess
in more detail but basically what these
on what these sisters dead is that they
created one of the first search engines
called Magellan in the mid nineties and
actually in that company it wasn't just
the twins but also ghilane Maxwell have
a stake in that as of her brother Kevin
Maxwell who was sort of Robert Maxwell's
heir apparent and sort of inherited the
his media empire after his death but of
course collapsed soon after because it
had you know was a major financial well
Robert Maxwell had stolen a lot of money
from his employees right he stole
hundreds of millions of dollars yeah
right well also it was it was more than
that it wasn't just the official story
is that he just embezzled funds for his
own use which is also true but the
reason the money for him to even
purchase that Media Group had come from
Assad and Mossad backers you know
financers of Mossad and so what a lot of
that money was used for there was
maxvill basically got in the habit
'unless odds behalf of taking money out
of that pitching fund it was used to
finance Mossad activities in Europe and
then after those operations concluded
the money would be put back in right to
these pension funds but as this was
going on over time maxvill started
taking money for him because he lived a
very ostentatious lifestyle he was very
fond of prostitutes and things of that
nature so you know he spent money on a
lot of thing
right right so his two daughters are
living in the u.s. at the time they
develop magellan yeah they moved to
Silicon Valley after Robert Maxwell died
and they created the search engine it
was sold off to excite it doesn't exist
anymore because you know Google
basically made it irrelevant right
though actually excite which acquired
this search engine tried to buy Google
at one point but it didn't work out but
um basically what happened after this
company was sloth Magellan was sold off
is that christine maxwell created this
company called chiliad and what chiliad
basically it basically became this data
analysis software that after September
11th was heavily promoted as its well I
don't know how much you have gone into
911 on your show right but basically it
was claimed after the official narrative
of 9/11 came out that only this software
was capable of connecting the dots that
explained the official narrative of 9/11
that you know US intelligence missed
prior to the attacks rate and so after
that the 9/11 Commission acclaimed
basically gave this company the only a
on their report card for
counterterrorism counterintelligence
software leading to it being installed
on all of these you know sensitive
databases in the US and what's
interesting is that one of the members
of the 9/11 Commission that pushed
really hard for chiliad was a guy named
John Lehman who was Secretary of the
Navy on the Reagan and used to be a
frequent guest on Robert Maxwell's ER so
this is like promised to ya
now it's amazing to me you had said on
Twitter that the type of operations that
obscene images lain were running we're
no longer going to be necessary or not
as necessary because a lot of blackmail
was now just going to be tech so explain
that because this is very interesting I
had no idea how how deeply connected the
Maxwell family was to these major tech
companies
oh yeah well actually Isabel Maxwell had
a separate company that's an Israeli
based company that's now called on siren
but was previously called comm touch and
she was the president of that company
and they run their software is
integrated into numerous aspects of
Microsoft Windows they're run by Google
and also on Dell computers right so you
know it's not just Christine's chiliad
it's also you know running on all these
Windows computers all over the world
Isabel's Maxwell stuff but anyway in
terms of what I'm saying about why the
people that's people have sponsored
Epstein and d'Alene you know are
favoring tech stuff is because I mean
all you have to do is look at what
Epstein did started to do right before
he was arrested last year or what he was
doing right before he was arrested last
year what he started to do around the
year 2012 this is a really key year for
a lot of this stuff right what he
started to do is he started to rebrand
as a tech investor he got interested in
Silicon Valley he started going to a lot
of Silicon Valley parties and he claimed
that he had a lot of blackmail on people
from Silicon Valley right and he was
talking you know he had ties what so
like Elon Musk he was I convinced with
Mark Zuckerberg he was he invited Sergey
Brin one of the Google co-founders over
to his house he was really ingratiating
himself with Silicon Valley's elite
right which was very interesting
especially when you consider the fact
that he was one of the major funders of
a company called carbine nine-one-one
that was chaired and directed until just
very recently by a hoot Barak Wright who
was head of Israeli military
intelligence
when Epstein was recruited to work there
which was facilitated by Robert Maxwell
the 1980s right and then eight who
Barack was Prime Minister of Israel um
and was you know went to Epstein's
Island he also went to the apartments on
by Epstein's brother that were full of
underaged Eastern European girls and
spent the night there on several
occasions right so this is the new
battleground for information clearly is
is the digital space so if you're an
intelligent
agency and you want to gain knowledge
you want to gain information and power
and blackmail the way to do that now is
through blackmail as opposed to like
just the honeypot operations that they
were writing on Epstein's Island and
right do you think the entire families
involved like you have choose lane
sisters doing this do they do they know
what they're doing are all of these
people oh yeah right
so like Maxwell's companies that she's
involved in is called Israel venture
capital I believe and one of their main
backers is a venture capital firm called
Leela Capital Partners and they are made
by Israel's former members of Israel's
unit 8200 which is part of Israel's
military intelligence and they openly
say they only invest in companies that
are full of former Israeli military
intelligence guys but on you know
talking about this whole tech thing and
what I brought up about 2012 it's really
important to point some things out
because basically I think they got to
the point where they don't even try and
hide it anymore so in 2012 this policy
began and this was reported in Israeli
media but not in the US media right
these former and current government and
intelligence officials told this Israeli
media outlet calculus tech that in 2012
this decision was made to take
operations that have previously been
conducted in-house by Mossad and
Israel's military intelligence and to
spin them off and have them be instead
conducted by private companies some of
which were created for that explicit
purpose one of those companies named in
the article is black Hugh right who's
former board of chairman used to be Meir
Dagan head of the Mossad and of course
they basically act like a privatized
Mossad right but they weren't set up to
be an actual privatized Mossad and they
are not the only company like this there
have been numerous companies that have
just excuse a since 2012 that have been
direct beneficiaries of that policy
right so an example would be this
company called cyber reason whose CEO
basically he straight-up says he an
interview it's just really crazy
he says his his work at this company
side reason which is a cyber security
company is a direct
can you Asian of his service to unit
8200 and at unit 8200 he was the head of
the unit that was involved in the
hacking offensive hacking of
nation-states right and he's at the
cybersecurity company which by the way
is running on a bunch of Pentagon
computers CIA NSA computers just like
Juliet was and it's no coincidence I
think that chiliads operations in the US
as the US government contractors started
to wind down right in 2012 when this new
policy became you know overt right right
I mean this is why I mean you've done so
much research it's amazing you keep all
these names of these companies yeah yes
straight because it's very hard I'm sure
to find these things out I mean I'm sure
you know you do research everything like
that what do you say to people that say
that this is a paranoid or that it's
anti-semitic or any of the things that I
see people throw at you on Twitter which
i don't think there's a basis for it's
not your fault that Robert Maxwell did
not work for you know French
intelligence you know right well what do
you say to people that say this is
probably mean I again I it's amazing to
me that this guy we know is a spy his
daughters running a honey pot with
Epstein his other two daughters are
selling software to the to the US
government security software and who are
the other kids but I mean before that
what is it what what do you say to
people that go she just hates Jews right
so the reason my focus said ever since
I've been writing is to report under
covered stories and unfortunately there
is just a lack of coverage of these
things that report I just mentioned that
when peered in the Israeli media outlet
capitalist tech should have been covered
in the u.s. you would think that would
be big news right but now I'm covered it
right so I you know okay so I think that
should be covered so I'm going to cover
it right and so you know a lot of my
research just ended up being on under
covered things a lot of which had to do
with Israel but I think it's very you
know important also but let's keep in
mind too that a lot of this specific you
know this use you know 8,200 and these
Mossad companies or whatever a lot of
them have members of US intelligence or
you know people from the US national
secure
stay on their board or as investors and
things like that I mean it's definitely
something that transcends just Israel as
a nation and involves you know us
intelligence also British intelligence
you know and things like that
you know Israel even just as a state had
a lot of the reason a lot of the reason
it even exists as a state is because of
you know the politics and the actions of
the British Empire at the time and also
the United States right right so and
it's like when you're talking about the
Mossad you're not talking about Israeli
people or Jewish people and it's like
when I say when I say the CIA killed
Kennedy I don't mean my uncle Steve
killed Kennedy I mean the CIA you know
yeah sure so if you're sizing Mossad and
people said it's anti-semitic I mean
that's sort of like if you want to
criticize the CIA in the US and people
are like oh that's anti-american I mean
who thinks that right intelligence
agencies by virtue of what they do
operate as organized criminal
organization right they deserve to be
criticized right if it is really
intelligence was involved in a pedophile
honey pot like Epstein and Maxwell well
it's also historical fact the CIA has
been involved in numerous such
operations in the past right so it's
okay to criticize the CIA for doing a
horrible act like that but it's not okay
to criticize you know Israel Israeli
intelligence right you know it's okay
them to support pedophilia right in the
pursuit of political control and
influence I mean no so I you know it's
just a matter of I'm just willing to
talk about this and a lot of people
unfortunately or not right so who the
other kids we have you have Isabel you
have just Layne Maxwell you have Isabel
who's the other Isaac total there were
like seven siblings and one of them died
when she was like 3 years old there was
another one that died at 23 but a lot of
the other ones that are best well-known
are Kevin and Ian Maxwell who recently
just set up a think tank called like
combating jihadist extremism great or
something like that
um but nobody in the business family
who's like an electrician right so
anyway Kevin Maxwell
has ties to banks like Goldman Sachs but
he got um you know his his public
reputation as a businessman really took
a huge nose dive because of what
happened to his father's media empire
that he inherited after Robert Maxwell's
death and became known as one of the
biggest bankrupt and I love Britain and
things like that
but I think there's a lot more to these
guys than in the official story because
in some of these old reports that you
can find up and dig up from the 90s that
are talking about where is the Maxwell
family now from like British media
they'll say things like this year you
know Ian Maxwell is director of 31
different companies okay so like if
someone spends all their time being
directors of companies you know or on
boards of companies you know it's like
under 10 I mean 30 is a lot so given
Robert Maxwell's history of having just
like infinite front companies I think
it's very possible that some of the
Maxwell boys we're also doing that
because it wasn't just Ian Maxwell that
had you know randomly 30 companies you
know Kevin Maxwell had like another
report said you got 22 I've been you
know in this particular year so between
the two of them they're directors over
50 companies a lot of which don't exist
anymore and they go bankrupt and then
they just disappear and then they make
new ones
I mean it's all very odd but it's worth
pointing out to you that Robert Maxwell
was very controlling of his children and
was also known to have set up lots of
companies and lots of small corporate
entities for their use so for example
when ghilane Maxwell after her father's
death moves to New York City she obtains
control of something Robert Maxwell had
already made for her called Maxwell
corporate gifts in which she started to
move money around and people can
understand how she is officially
supposed to have a small income because
the father's you know media empire
collapse and they're supposed to have no
money right but somehow she's able to
just come up with all these millions of
course that's later claimed that's
Epstein's but she had this you know
these corporate entities just waiting
for her around for her use right yes as
soon as she got there yeah so
intelligence is the family business
clearly yeah so you have you have the
two sisters running tech companies you
have the two brothers run
in front companies why does juice Lane
get the pedophile ring do you think he
was it Christmas was going or Hanukkah
whatever was going through everybody and
goes you're gonna do TAC you're gonna do
this and you're in just Lane you're
gonna do pedophilia
and with Sheila but I want to do Tech
and he's like you're not meant for that
you go put those girls in a van right so
a lot of times in media reports the lane
is sort of treated as you know they say
oh she's the the child I've inherited
his charisma and socially ambition and
all of this but apparently as I
mentioned earlier Robert Maxwell had you
know Pitt spent tons of money on
prostitutes and actually when he would
go to visit Israel um they would have
several prostitutes waiting for him upon
his arrival right so he was kind of an
interesting guy right so they smoked me
know about d'Alene it seems like she
seemed to have inherited that as well
but let's talk about the types of
circles but Blaine Maxwell wasn't
involved in the 1980s before she started
this operation with Epstein in 1991
right as an example she was involved
with some guy that later you know had
close ties to this guy this conservative
politician and the UK named Harvey
Proctor Harvey Proctor was accused of
being part of the VIP pedophile ring the
same one that was run by Jimmy Savile
and also involved former prime minister
of the UK Ted Heath right so this is one
of the people she was dating during that
period of time allegedly one of her
other boyfriends that preceded Epstein
was this Italian guy who was a count and
his grandfather was Mussolini's finance
minister and had deep ties to Italian
intelligence right so these are the
kinds of people she was dating also
other weird things she was known to have
been associated with the royal family
then Maria farmer saw pictures of her
you know with Prince Andrew at quite
young ages like teeny young teenagers
and things like that right so those ties
go back quite far because the royal
family had ties that whole seville jimmy
savile network and also a lot of you
know shady activities like that which is
why it's not that odd I guess at the end
of the day why Prince Andrew would
associate himself with people like
Jeffrey Epstein in a public way years
later
right but another thing that's odd about
the lane one incident that has gotten
like very little coverage that the lien
was involved involved in in the 1980s is
that in 1985 she throws a gala at this
house of these Nobles British Nobles who
I believe were like the the mark
Marquess of bath or something like that
words were their titles and it was it
was to benefit save the children right
in 1985 and right after that dollar
ended the son of those Nobles of the
Marquess of Bath was found hanging dead
hanging with a bedspread around his neck
and that's like you know normal for
d'Alene I guess hold on go over that
again you there she's having a dinner
party for the notes right it's a it's a
gala
yeah the children okay right yeah the
organisation or whatever and it's held
at these nobles house the Marquess of
Bath right yeah it succeeded by members
of the royal family right at the end the
gala the son of the Marcus of Bath is
found dead hanging with a bedspread
around his neck at a separate location
but it's immediately after this gala
that he was at that was hosted at his
parents house just seems odd and also
odd that someone like d'Alene Maxwell
who at that same time was involved with
this guy that was you know had this
close relationship with Harvey Proctor
is going on and she's throwing a party
for Save the Children and if anyone
wants to look into that organization
I really recommend the work of
independent journalist Vanessa B Lee who
has shown very convincingly that Save
the Children is into a lot of very shady
things and has been for a long time yeah
that's why I don't donate to charity
across the board um I love your buds but
they suck apples socks they're a cult
you know China the whole thing I mean
not that I have a problem in China but
you know I you know it's there's you
know there's questions the newest model
the e25 earbuds are the best ones yet
with six hours of play time that's
what's really great about these things I
have them and they just go six hours and
what are you doing this longer than six
hours okay see
was bluetooth pairing more bass and a
compact design that gives you a nice
noise-isolating fit ray comes wireless
earbuds are so comfortable they're
perfect for conference calls our binging
podcast so if you want to go on a hike
or a long workout or you just want to
clean your house it's gonna take a few
hours there's no worry that these things
are gonna die out
you know the Apple earbuds die out
immediately okay ray cotton ear buds are
both stylish and discreet with no
dangling wires or stems to distract
anyone during video calls you've heard
me talk about how the company was
co-founded by Ray J and other
celebrities Snoop Dogg cardi B you know
Melissa answered all my personal friends
are obsessed with Ray Khan's pick up a
pair and see what the hype is all about
I love these because they do last six
hours you've done it then they charge up
very quickly when they go another six
hours it's so important so now's the
time to get the latest and greatest from
Ray Khan
this really helps our show and it helps
you if you need earbuds and if you don't
buy them anyway and have them there coz
you're gonna lose your Apple ones and
you don't want to go back into the Apple
store they don't even exist you have to
go online it's all process and they suck
anyway so get 15% off your order by
rakin comm slash tim t IM that's by
Raycom slash t IM use the promo code 15%
off your order
for wireless earbuds it helps fund the
work that we do here and the work that
ray con does these headphones are great
you're gonna love it I enjoy them they
last very long thank you when I was a
kid my favorite cereal was Lucky Charms
and my parents would never buy them for
me but I love sugar cereals in fact many
fat people get hooked on sugar cereals
when they're children that's why the
cereals are always three feet all the
bad cereals are low they're like three
or four feet tall so that the kids kid
they're on the eye line of the child in
the store the child can grab them
it's an old advertising trick old
marketing trick okay but here no tricks
just goodness magic spoon cereal is one
of my favorites you can indulge in any
of the classic flavors cocoa fruity
frosted or blueberry plus a variety pack
that lets you try all four my favorite
flavor is fruity it tastes like fruit
loops exactly it simulates the
experience you've had when you're
eating Froot Loops at your grandparents
house from your child and life made
sense
MAGIX booth spent over a year working
with the best food scientists and chefs
in the world to recreate the taste and
texture and that's the most important
thing of classic sugary cereal but it
tastes so incredible that you'd never
guess it was healthy its keto friendly
what gluten-free [ __ ] you grain free
[ __ ] your mother
soy free one low carb I'll kill you
where you stand and gmo-free you've got
to try to believe it it tastes amazing
everybody loves magic spoon everybody
buys it's a little pricey but what is
the price you put on your health and
your children's health if you have
children you need to get them on this
cereal I'm telling you right now
otherwise it can grow up to be fat
little pigs magic spoon calm slash Tim
Dillon magic spoon calm slash Tim Dillon
grab a variety pack and try it today our
promo code is Tim Dillon at checkout you
get free shipping it's easy it's my name
I love the cereal I eat it everyone in
Hollywood eats it it's and and and if
you hate Hollywood everyone in your
favorite culture eats it whether it's
sports or the Trump family all each said
everyone at Fox News eats it it's Tucker
Carlson's favorite whatever you want
whatever you like you know everybody
eats this the Democrats to Republicans
everybody you don't want to know what
Jeffery up sees last meal was magic
spoon cereal he had it and he said
nothing could possibly be better than
this so I'm going to hang myself right
after it after he had magic spoons
fruity flavor he he said the one of the
guards he goes what is this and the
guard goes it's it's some Kido cereal
actually goes this is Kido and the guys
like yeah MC goes string me up because I
don't believe it I call me crazy but if
the cereal could taste this good and be
Quito there's nothing else good coming
we've reached the zenith point of
civilization hang me from this bed that
looks like it would be hard to hang me
from because I'm six foot something so
and
he did it and he did it out of joy he
was so happy
magic spoon cereal it's just I love it
you love it the kids love it everybody
loves it get your little fat kids
[ __ ] hands off the bad [ __ ] and get
them on the magic spoon if your you
should be arrested for child abuse with
what you served the kids child abuse go
through any grocery store everything
that's aimed for kids is like disgusting
it's like s'mores puddin pops you know
with Jolly Ranchers sauce deep-fried
it's grotesque give them something nice
something that they'll remember I know
they'll they'll grow up to to love you
not like you know the way [ __ ] you
know I feel about my family which is I I
it's a strong light but I also if they
were killed in a drone strike I would I
would say yeah yeah so the way I feel is
you go to magic spoon calm slash Tim
Dylan magic spoon calm slash Tim Dylan
eat it if you're getting if you're
getting ready for a wedding you're
getting ready for a wedding man this is
it if you're trying to lose weight you
want to use the summer to get in shape
your quarantine you can't go out anyway
get get that summer bod ready for next
summer you know when all the oceans are
running blood red with the blood of the
whatever um but you'll still look hot
you'll still look hot magic spoon comm
slash Tim Dylan really tried I would III
and the most honest person in the
country and I'm telling you right now
I've eaten the cereal I've enjoyed the
cereal I will enjoy the cereal again and
I will never I will not speak to my
parents until they start eating this
cereal so what are these people all
united by just having millions of
dollars and having sex with children is
this seem to be how our entire planet
run no I mean is a genuinely serious
question like when we start is this
who's running the planet I mean it seems
to all kind of add up where it's like
they use this you know sick thing to
keep each other in check how do you
think this all
works to these people just is this is
just a way to keep people quiet keep
them in line they all party I mean is
there anybody who's successful like is
there anyone who's not a pedophile who's
doing it like you know what I mean like
well I mean I can't really speak I can't
really give you a definitive answer to
that but you know what I can say is that
you know a lot of people in this orbit
right the this Epstein Network whatever
you want to call it just have a history
of just blackmail or ties to organized
crime or ties to intelligence right
right and blackmail for these people I
mean they don't live like regular people
do you know all right so like take West
register for example right where Maria
farmers on his guest house she was like
normal people don't live like this you
know they spent hours watching her
through pinnable cameras in that guest
house right see everything doing I mean
that's not how normal people live they
have so much money but they're so
paranoid right I mean because that's not
like mob families are and that's how
these families are - right and you look
at someone like the Bronfman family
that's tied up in a lot of this stuff -
they were tied up in nexium right which
also had like elements of blackmail and
all of that better - and then also like
you know I'm one of agra brahmins kids
tried to blackmail him in the 1980s
faking his own kidnapping and things
like that it was on father right like
more my dad yeah like that's just all
these families just seem to operate I
mean it's you almost feel bad for them
but then you realize what their
horrendous evil criminals that belong
behind bars for the rest of their lives
people right but I mean they're just
like they don't exist like we do like
regular people do I guess you know right
there constantly jockeying for position
it's like kind of like Game of Thrones
you have all these powerful families
they all have tons of money they all
want more money it's never enough and
any information they have on each other
or any any of these you know elite
circles that they can penetrate there
seems to be some type of cost of
admission and it might not always be
pedophilia but it also could be like
financial crime
or it could be like your willingness to
you know infiltrate a government agency
and give information it's everybody's
got something on somebody else so just
lean saying but look you know let's keep
in mind to you that like this practice
sexual blackmail and these types of
operations including those involving
children I mean they go back to like the
1940s right possibly even earlier right
the fact that they doing this for so
long it's just like well this is how
things are and as long as we stick you
now abide by a certain set of rules that
this group follows with whatever you
know we can you know rape kids as much
as you want and stuff like that right
and you know yeah what gets me is like
is there anyone looks like instead of
raping kids let's go on the boat like is
there any rich person who's like let's
not rape kids today we can have brunch
like it is there anybody should let's
let's time is crazy it's like yeah um in
truly evil human beings the Clintons and
Trump I don't want to the reason I
haven't asked you until this long in the
interview is I don't want this to be a
political story like I don't want it to
be politicized and become a battering
ram where people on the left go Trump
and people in the right parts right it
is bipartisan yeah right
evil satanic pedophile cabal's are
bipartisan and my audience should know
that where do you see that the cleanse
of the Trump's how are they in meshed in
this are they just kind of functionaries
in terms of they run the United States
government how close are they with these
people
alright neither of them are clean but in
order to really explain the
relationships of the relate their
relationships to this whole thing I mean
it takes some time right because the
official stories about their involvement
are just in my opinion very superficial
and I guess probably one of the easiest
to start with because the trap lines
more complex because a lot of it
precedes mm right a lot of the closer
involvement between Trump and have seen
happen before them and but that's also
true for Bill Clinton great because the
the official story about you know Bill
Clinton and Epstein says that Bill
Clinton did involved with that scene
until he wasn't president anymore
this is yes great so what we know right
as I mentioned earlier so like that the
clintons had some involvement this
promise software stuff I mean they were
kind of in this orbit anyway nothing you
know not just to promise but also the
iran-contra stuff which this epstein
network and the Maxwells and all the
stuff we're also involved through what
was going on in Mena Arkansas Arkansas
I mean involved in Iran Contra in a huge
way Bill Clinton had a relationship with
the CIA with Bill Casey bill bar
actually acted as an emissary of Bill
Casey to Bill Clinton on several
occasions right another reason why he is
shady is [ __ ] right so anyway that's how
the clip you know this is all before he
even becomes president but as soon as he
becomes president
remember that Epstein and Maxwell
officially teamed up in New York in 1991
as soon as he becomes president in 1993
they are attending donor dinners fancy
donor dinners right for the Clintons and
not long after that Jeffrey Epstein
that same year makes several White House
visits and he meets the WD chief of
staff on several occasions what they
discussed I don't really know but in
1995 we do know that Lynn Forrester now
Lynn Forrester de Rothschild
right since this letter to Bill Clinton
that you can find actually was provided
by the presidential library of Bill
Clinton it says basically talks about
how she had met Bill Clinton at senator
then senator Ted Kennedy's house and she
didn't have much time to talk to him and
had all these other things he wanted to
talk about him and she said in what she
called this this brief window of time to
talk to the president
these were 15 seconds of access she
talked to Bill Clinton about two things
currency stabilization and Jeffrey
Epstein this is in 1995 in 1995 maria
farmer was decorating right and working
as this artist in residence for d'Alene
Maxwell Jeffrey Epstein she remembers a
more than one occasion where everyone
was ordered out but they spent all day
preparing for Bill Clinton to come and
Elaine Maxwell was running around
yelling the president coming and all
this stuff and the only people that were
allowed
was the personal chef of Epstein who
died last month
under sudden circumstances of no funeral
because of the coronavirus right
everyone's ordered out with the chef and
the girls there's no security detail for
Bill Clinton and he's a sitting
president at this time right so very
strange right and this is all before the
official you know the relationship comes
out in the open and Epstein is involved
and the Clinton Foundation ghilane is
involved in the Clinton Global
Initiative all of the island visits the
flight logs and all of that takes place
right right so they're what are Hillary
and Bill doing right now I mean other
than sharpening knives
what do you think that or do you think
they're do you think you're nervous to
these people get nervous are these
elites kind of like oh well I think what
the delay Mac's will arrest I don't
think any of these people are really
nervous based on how this is going to
play out because I think it's going to
be a very secretive protracted legal
trial that is going to get buried in the
insane news cycle in which we now live
which involves coronavirus of civil
unrest protests major TV political
tensions I mean it's very easy to bury
the Epstein story unlike last year and
like I said it's it's very clear to me
anyway they're gonna let her post bail
and she's not going to end up in the
situation Epstein was in because
actually was only there because he
wasn't and he was denied bail do you
think they're gonna let miss lane
Maxwell the definition of a flight risk
post bail uh yeah I think wow but
because of the charges she's facing they
are so light right right in contrast to
Epstein right who last year was denied
bail because of the you know his being
the crimes were much more egregious that
he was officially charged with is what
I'm talking about right so you know to
deny someone the ability to post bail
when they are only charged with enticing
minors to travel yeah you know why did
they choose those charges specifically
why didn't they charge her with
statutory rape why did they you know
keep it up 94 to 1997 right well
actually I can tell you why it's because
in that period of time Prince Andrew and
alan dershowitz were not in Bill Clinton
officially we're not on the orbit yet
right so they don't have to be drugged
you know pulled into this trial of
coming trial billing Maxwell focuses on
a time when none of them were you know
officially involved interesting so
there's no chance they get pulled into
it yeah right
now what about Trump is there any chance
he's pulled into it in any way well no
because well based on these charges now
right but you know Trump in in his ex
wife Ivana were in the epstein horbet to
a significant degree during that
timeframe right rumored Maria farmer you
know said that she personally witnessed
he bought a Trump going out with d'Alene
and recruiting preteen girls and school
uniforms to come by Jeffrey Epstein's
office and you know see if they could be
future Victoria's Secret models yeah
it's really crazy Trump did kick Epstein
out of Moral ago because he was hitting
on an underage girl so we'll get well
there there's a longer history to them
right because it okay right so you have
to go back to the 1980s and see what
Epstein was doing then right so
basically what she was doing in this
period of time he was doing a lot of
shady financial activity for
intelligence and intelligence operatives
but he was also with Leslie Wexner doing
a lot of money money laundering through
real estate and a lot of shady real
estate deals at Manhattan right of
course that trumps whole orbit too right
and during this period of time in the
1980's the epstein Trump in the sky
named Tom Barrett who's still pretty
close to Trump and head of Colony
Capital were called the three musketeers
of New York Life nightlife because they
would go to clubs and like you know get
with women together and be seen together
like so frequently and they were all in
that same you know same age range more
or less involved same shady real estate
deals and that ultimately were a lot of
that relationship comes from though it's
worth pointing out that Maria farmer did
say that in 1995 she saw Donald Trump
and he gave her this just buried she
found it to be a very disturbing look
and the Jeff
instead the [ __ ] oh she's not here for
you implying that there was some other
type of girl that she would that he
would set Trump up with right but this
was one occasion but it was enough to
make an impact on her right and of
course there is that accusation who this
girl who claimed that she had been raped
by Trump at this event with Epstein in
like in 1994 I believe it was so there
are these claims going around but as far
as I'm you know I I see it right a lot
of their relationship was based around
the shady real-estate stuff that FC
continued to do well into the late 1990s
why was they were falling out between
Epstein and Trump well a lot of it had
to do with this property in Palm Beach
that Jeffrey Epstein wanted to buy
ostensibly for this money-laundering
real estate purpose or some shady real
estate deal he invites Trump to come see
the property and Trump you know says oh
you know they talk about it whatever and
then Trump ends up stealing that
property from Epstein and doing what
Epps he wanted to do and sells it to
like this really rich Eastern European
guy maybe like Russian billionaire or
something like that who never actually
lives in the property but pays a bunch
of money for it and then it just gets
like the house gets demolished and you
know really shady transaction basically
of clutch after that apparently what
Epstein tried to do at mar-a-lago when
he was kicked out had to do with an
attempt by f seem to get back at Trump
for what had happened there and sort of
get Trump set up with a minor or have a
minor get caught in some sort of
situational situation at moral agro to
put pressure on Trump so this is just a
game they play this is this is the way
that people are playing this game
what do you are there other intelligence
families that are similar to the
Maxwells where you have a lot of
different kids I mean is this something
like you have families of you know very
successful people in sports or you have
felt like why they're just intelligence
families is this a bill bill bar and
Donald bar I believe bill bars daughter
also is involved you know in the DOJ as
some sort of prosecutor related to drug
trafficking which is interest
considering you know her father's in the
involvement with the CIA during
iran-contra which was also you know in
arms trafficking and drug trafficking
scandal right so it's like a lot of
these families like the Bronfman family
is are they do you think they have ties
they they're pretty big pretty big yeah
I mean that well they're part of this
whole maggot group thing that was
co-founded by trails Brompton and Leslie
Wexler in 1991 and a lot of people I
mean most of the members of that have
ties to or the national crime syndicate
which is that you know the coming
together really of the Italian mafia and
the Jewish mob in the early 20s that got
in bed with the CIA during World War two
and the Jewish mob aspect of that got
very involved with Israeli intelligence
as soon as it was formed after the siege
of Israel because Blake Robert Maxwell
they were involved in sending large
amounts of weapons to Zionist peer
militaries that resulted in the creation
of the State of Israel and then after
you know Mossad and the IDF and all that
stuff was created was involved in
sending a lot of weapons or money to
finance their operations yeah right so I
mean the ties are very in meshed and so
you know the Jewish mob aspect that was
run by like mainly like Mayr Lansky and
all of that stuff during that period of
time have deep ties to intelligence and
also the political you know sphere of
both countries right so like the mega
group for example Ronald Lauder close
friend of Trump is basically
single-handedly responsible for Benjamin
Netanyahu's first election as Israeli
prime minister in 1996 right so you know
he has pull there you know he's also a
major donor to US politicians right
another guy who sort of in this mega
group orbit is this hedge fund manager
named Paul singer right who's a big
donor to LaHood he's also head of the
Republican Jewish coalition a major
donor to neo-cons like Marco Rubio and
members of the Republican Party that are
very you know neoconservative and things
like that he's also the guy in 2012 that
created this organization called
start-up nation central which is a
direct part of that 2012 policy in unit
8200 private companies tech companies
that I was talking about earlier and
it's actually you know based in you know
have Paul singer as an American right
he started that organization with the
explicit purpose of having us tech jobs
transferred over to Israel and also
having these unit 18 8200 companies
acquired by major US tech companies on
he officially said as it was so that the
US would have to be dependent on Israeli
companies so that they could the US
could never support the boycott
divestment sanctions yes right what is
the end game of all this tech supremacy
do you think is just to kind of strip
every one of all their rights you know
put everything you know about you in
some type of Bank whether it's you know
your health data your finance I think
you know Israel is essentially just
building the infrastructure for that
that's being used by the US I mean this
is that all of this is happening with
the complete blessing of the US
government US intelligence community
that's what you have like the former
chief information officer for the CIA
being on the board alongside an ex
Mossad director of this Israeli
scientists cyber security companies
scipio systems that's just one example
right right why are you yeah but you
know I think a really good case study
about like what are these companies
doing I mean I can speculate about what
the endgame is right but I think you can
you know sort of you know people that
are listening can you know come to their
own conclusions based on what a company
like carbine 911 is doing because
remember this is the company that FC put
a million dollars in it was directed and
chaired by a Barak former head of
Israeli military intelligence and former
Israeli prime minister and pedophile and
Epstein Powell right so what does part
by not carbine nine-one-one do well
actually before I even get there let's
talk about some of the u.s. people that
are on the board they have Michael
Chertoff former head of DHS they have
another former head of DHS the one that
resigned not that long ago that was
trapped under Trump Christian Nielsen is
also on there they of the former head of
LAPD and you know I'm forgetting the
rest of them but there's several former
US government officials and law
forcement officials that went on the
board of this company right Christian
they're all kidding
knowing no I don't think he's there
there was also a major at one point he's
not there anymore a major Trump done in
an Eliot to wheel he was in a New York
real estate developer and there's also
one of the other major investors in this
company is Peter Thiel head of Palantir
very close to the Trump administration
right and Palin tears area or Welling
and company who has been practicing
predictive policing in New Orleans for
several years right and has basically
been developing I mean they basically in
terms of like with the promise software
was capable of doing in terms of data
analysis on Palantir does that and
what's very creepy about Palin taters
they have a label that you can put on a
person and that label is titled
subversive and you can use that to track
their activities but you label the
person of interest subversive which
sounds quite odd right but anyway that's
just Palantir so these are the people
essentially behind carbine it was
co-founded right by all these X you know
8200 guys one of whom recently left the
company and now works for Aaron prints
so you know a fun group of people at the
end of the day right so what does this
thing do the carbine nine-one-one is
described as the next-generation 911 one
system the 911 system as it exists today
in the US is basically varies on a
county-by-county basis it's essentially
very fragmented there's no nationalized
emergency service system in the u.s. so
carbine nylon one claims to be the
answer to that they are very closely
tied to the main lobby that is pushing
for this next generation 9 1 1 which is
called mg 911 right um they're currently
being used in several US counties so
basically what is different about this
is that when you call part of a 9-1-1
with your smartphone the 9-1-1 operator
doesn't just have access to your audio
they also can see you on your camera and
they can get your geolocation but also
what happens when you call with a phone
any number that's connected and uses
carbon 9-1-1 all of the data off of your
phone gets sucked out of there and goes
into the car by 9-1-1 database so what
happens then they use artificial
intelligence to analyze every
then you've done in the past you said
all this data they pull off right and
they also use that to analyze everything
done through the past to the present
based on what's on your phone and they
use it to predict if you will be close
to the sea a scene of a crime in the
future if you will be a future victim of
a crime or a future perpetrator of a
crime what right that is terrifying yeah
and thanks to coronavirus they have
actually offered other services now
including remote government and have
partnered with the IRS and so no DMV
locations throughout the US I could just
imagine them looking at my post mates
and GrubHub orders trying to figure out
if I will be a victim of a heart attack
or a file be a perpetrator so it's all
it really so that's the end game the end
game is basically isolating certain
things about you and predicting whether
you're gonna commit a crime you might be
a victim of a crime and it's just
terrifying when they're just building a
key so you're calling 9-1-1 and they're
already building a case against you yeah
basically but it's not this is just one
system right there's another just like
this that I wrote about it came my
article on them came out just yesterday
called diagnostic robotics they are
playing the same idea of pre-crime
predictive technology to coronavirus and
lockdowns they have already partnered
with the state of Rhode Island right
right and this this algorithm is was
developed by the IDF right right and
it's founded by Xu 8200 people you know
it's just it's just and the real the
reason is like you could see like okay
contact tracing can prevent the spread
of a virus we can all agree that that
seems reasonable but this will never
stop there none of this ever stops there
so the contact tracing thing right it
was justified as that but what has
happened since then well then it moved
from coronavirus to the protests and
civil unrest contact tracing was used by
law enforcement right to track people
right so what do you think you know if
this diagnostic robotic system for
example predicts future potential
coronavirus hotspots let's point out let
me point out
person that created this company after
unit 8200 see what she was immediately
recruited by Microsoft she developed
predictive analytic AI base programs to
predict future health outbreaks but also
future outbreaks of riots and civil
unrest interesting interesting and
basically Israel is because they're
partnered with Israel's government and
they're using it there right now
they basically promoted as saying with
this technology we can lock down an area
or an entire town in less than a day
right right so what this is just a way
to establish really total control over
the US population or any population that
might be angry or they might be
protesting this is a way to kind of
clamp down on that really before it even
starts I mean that's the whole point
and what's really creepy about that
software is that they refer to a person
who might get coronavirus in the future
as a coronavirus patient at risk of
exposure
that's crazy implies that everyone is a
coronavirus patient and they're
currently developing a treatment system
whereby the government can use it and
have all this access to your smart
smartphone right and can develop this
whole system in fluent this whole system
to mandate medical treatment mandate
test and also mandate that you take a
vaccine when that becomes available and
they're piloting that right now in India
which is a major partner and a lot of
this tech stuff too cuz it's not just
the US right so the final frontier is
tack this is the message from Whitney
Webb this is where all of the
intelligence the types going this is
where Epstein started focusing all his
efforts you know in 2012 this is where
Colleen Maxwell's other family members
have been since the 90s crazy this is
really it's and and Google and companies
like that are are are on board and this
is gonna be and this will be you know if
you have an opinion that no one likes if
you ride
article if you do a podcast if you say
something on your social media that's
considered to be antisocial or hateful
or offensive you're gonna be able to be
removed from those platforms we're
already seeing that and it's going to be
a way to enforce this this kind of
consensus that doesn't exist because
people are gonna be like no I don't want
this or I'm angry about this but it's
not gonna matter because you can have
all the levers of power at their control
through these systems to just hoard
people anywhere they want them to go
yeah but they seemed like all of these
new movements that are popping like
black guys matter all this stuff these
companies seem to be paying those
movements a lot of lip service well I
think the ultimate goal of a lot of
these intelligence motivated operations
is about creating as much chaos in the
United States as possible because what
happens basically what they want to do
is they want to like clamp down right so
how can they justify that well if the
u.s. gets to a point where there's so
much division because a lot of these
people you know end up banking both
sides right so like the more divided the
u.s. is and the more chaos there is the
more they can justify the imposition of
order by force right so I mean I
ultimately think that's where a lot of
this is going I mean over ever since the
coronavirus thing started right you've
seen oh the National Guard oh there's
these continuity of government programs
that have been activated in case all of
Congress that's its coronavirus and
can't be there and then the military
will rule briefly right and then there
was the you know the protests of civil
unrest there were these stories like you
know this poll says the majority of
Americans want the military on the
streets on the end of Posse Comitatus to
restore order right right so they're you
know they're kind of pushing it along
that way it's like all the articles are
like this Paul says Americans want to be
vaccinated in their sleep you know 70
percent of Americans want yeah yeah
really manufacturing consent is what
it's about I mean that poll was probably
complete yes but what it's about is sort
of getting people like oh this is like I
can see this you know because that's
what pulsar emits I'm gonna be like
public opinion a lot of times and
manufactured consent for things right so
I mean that seems to be where a lot of
this is
it's worth pointing out to that company
I mentioned earlier in relation to the
Cena 8,200 stuff cyber reason last year
and since then also this year as well
have done several simulations with top
people in the US government that
simulated major terrorist attacks on
November 3rd 2020 election day and
there's a lot of this involved cyber
attacks on the power grid on sewage
systems self-driving cars which are now
being implemented in mass right with
coronavirus crashing into people waiting
line to vote murdering Americans among
other things right and this is a company
deeply tied to Israeli intelligence and
also US intelligence they're owned by
soft Bank which has ties to Jared
Kushner and Mohammed bin Salman of Saudi
Arabia and they're openly simulating you
know this is a company that they're
simulating terrorist attacks on Election
Day of this year yes and you know what's
also weird is that they have nothing to
gain fairly financially they sell cyber
security software antivirus software the
simulations they're conducting don't
involve the hacking of election machines
or any of any software or any device for
which their software operates right they
just claim to be doing it because
they're so worried that something bad
could happen to us do you think all
these DDoS attacks that we blame on
China is that a possibility that some of
those are maybe you know routine like
that they're running these types of
simulations give you an example people
may have heard but it's not really the
China but you know you can see how unit
8200 operates hundred again just for
everyone who might have forgot like me
what is Union 8200 it's signals
intelligence unit of Israel's military
diamonds they're being okay like you
know NSA got basically so I forgot oh
yeah okay so for as an example of how
they sort of operate right people may
remember that there was a story that ran
I believe first in the Wall Street
Journal that said that Kaspersky
antivirus software which is you know I
think it's like a Russian company right
and it was running on some US government
computers they claimed that have had a
backdoor right for Russian intelligence
okay and this was widely reported and of
course in the climate you know if Russia
gating all of this it made some
headlines the origin of that claim
didn't come out until weeks later when
it was revealed that that claim was
given to us officials by members of unit
8200 what happens afterwards Kaspersky
is banned from being installed on u.s.
computers but who takes over and who
becomes the antivirus replacement cyber
reason Wow so yeah it's just meet the
new boss kind of same as the O's
another thing about the cyber attacks um
new york's power grid is currently being
operated by us israeli state-owned
military contractors currently run the
hydroelectric dams in new york and most
of its power grid running the software
when they look at the american media and
so much of it is left first right and
and so many people in america are left
first right is it ever frustrating to
you that nobody kind of sees the bigger
picture where a lot of these people are
on the same side no matter what they say
because the whole left-right paradigm is
to distract people from the fact that
the left and the right you know the
democrats and republicans with numerous
policies you know there's essentially
the same they all support endless war
they all support I don't know the
Federal Reserve they all support the
Israel lobby and you know giving Saudi
Arabia eight billion dollars to Israel
at a time when how many Americans are
unemployed now right right right now I
mean they're all policies that don't
change regardless of who's president
regardless even has a majority in
Congress so you know basically the only
disagreements are over like a handful of
social issues abortion gay rights you
know maybe that's standed a little bit
more since they've tried to like you
know move the Left farther to the left
and the right part right and all of this
right but it's essentially the same now
I'm talking about the billionaires that
have totally intelligence agencies that
are [ __ ] both everyone over right
right so that's so that of course it's
frustrating but in terms of the big
picture I'm only just covering you know
talking about you know we've been
talking a lot about Israeli intelligence
today because of bajo Epstein op right
but this is just one aspect of the big
picture
but I think you know one of the reasons
that Israeli tack and all of this is
being used is because no one in the US
media talks about them so it's the
perfect cover you know they could be
doing this on behalf of US intelligence
and you don't know that right now what
is it nobody knew us meaner nobody in
the US media talked about them is it
because they they get hit with you no
one wants to be called anti-semitic
right right um you know but you know
there's there's some other examples
right so for example there was this
really great journalist I don't think he
writes a lot anymore named Chris Ketchum
on he did a lot of really great work on
Israeli espionage the Israeli art
student espionage scandal in the early
2000s and also on continuity of
government programs and how terrifying
they are right because they were
originally created by like people like
Dick Cheney and Rumsfeld in the 1980s
and I really recommend people look into
that but right after he published some
of this stuff on his really art students
and and Israeli espionage in general and
continuity of government right and some
promise software stuff the whole
magazine he wrote at which was called
radar was shut down one of the major
shareholders in radar at the time was
Jeffrey Epstein Wow well well Whitney
Webb I want to thank you for being on
our last show on YouTube we appreciate
that you know we'll be in a safe house
with you tell everybody where they could
support your work it's fascinating stuff
you do a lot of work I mean you keep the
names of these companies straight and
the investors straight and I mean again
nobody very few people in the US media
are doing this types of stuff and I mean
just to say another thing we all need
security we all we know that the
purported you know like you know the
purported reason for these intelligence
agencies to exist makes a lot of sense
to people but what people really need to
understand is that this is way beyond
the scope of like defending America or
offending Israel or defending the UK
this is going into
on another arena and it's actually
preventing people from getting anything
out of their government like it's
actually preventing people from
exercising any self control over their
own government because it completely
stacks the deck against any type of
representative democracy when you have
this group of elites blackmailing each
other controlling the media it's a
problem
absolutely well you know it's one
pointing out these intelligence agencies
really like the CIA since it was created
as function as an organized criminal
network right you know as the mob right
and so what they're interested in doing
is protecting their business interests
in illicit trades you know as the mob
right whether it's drug running arms
trafficking human trafficking the CIA
does all of that let's remember the
CIA's first director was at this is not
only a Nazi sympathizer he used to work
for Sullivan and Cromwell which before
the CIA existed used to Dooku's abroad
in places like Panama on behalf of
corporate clients and that is what the
CIA started off doing underground is
leadership right right you know the coup
they launched was over bananas you know
instant real America when they overthrew
government because of banana interests
right hey it's just like he was doing it
sold in a crowd long it's been like that
ever since right it's never been about
defending America right for the CIA
right right and so the fact that they've
never been held accountable for this
because any president or any you know
you know gets shot in the head right
right you know and just think of all the
assassinations in the six Nixon was
removed Kennedy was assassinated Reagan
was shot I mean this happened to all the
time yeah Martin Luther King was John I
mean Bobby Kennedy yeah the list of
assassinations in this country or
attempted assassinations is wild right
we're ruled by criminals well by law and
people really need to realize this
because these people have had infinite
resources for years they know how to
play us off each other and against each
other and they're what they want to do
can only succeed if we continue to let
them you know play us like that
right right you have to recognize you
know as a country that the enemy isn't
like you know the person on the left or
the person on the right the person you
don't go agree with politically it's the
people the criminals that have
orchestrated all this [ __ ] from the
beginning that are at the top and now
you see the cracks like you see the
cracks and you people have always seen
them but now things here are no good
like it is getting bad and people can
see that like people can see and feel
that this country is coming apart at the
seams and a lot of people are looking
for a reason and one of the reasons is
because these guys have gotten away with
so much for so long and there's only so
long you can you know run a country like
this take all of the money deny people
you know basic liberties until they're
become you get to a tipping point where
people are broke they're out of work
they're angry they're frustrated
frustrated whatever people always
criticize always say that word and and
people are really they've had it people
have had it for good reason so final
question and then I want you to after
you answer it I want you to tell
everyone where to find you
is there a chance that just Layne
Maxwell does no jail time and ends up
you know back in some estate and Europe
yeah and that's why I think it's really
critical you know I've seen a lot of
people online celebrating for being
arrested and sure it's great that she's
not in a mansion in New Hampshire right
now allegedly right but what people need
to do is to put the political pressure
on and be like these charges are a joke
and they're not enough right I mean what
they're trying to do here in my opinion
is that after what happened with Epstein
last August right but one of the reasons
this case refused to go away even though
they wanted it to was because people
were like where is the lay right well
now they found Elaine and they're
charging her and now people are praising
this right and so if we allow them to
set the narrative that this is justice
for what gleen did then they will you
know seal it off and they'll work their
best to memory :
right yeah so the way to fight against
that is to be like these charges are
[ __ ] this woman is a serial
pedophile rape
sex trafficker who was sponsored by a
foreign state and also had ties to
intelligence here too right
those states their agencies need to be
held accountable
this woman belongs and behind bars for
the rest of her life and charging her
for enticing minors to travel is not
enough I mean the woman I mean there are
articles you know from before FC was
even arrested the first time talking
about how the lane would brandish whips
and trained young girls and sex
techniques people knew this stuff was
going on and we're supposed to believe
that the FBI is investigating in good
faith and they're charging her for stuff
from 1994 to 1997 and 2025 we're
supposed to be like good job yeah I I
don't know I mean this is just you know
a clear indictment of this two-tier
justice system someone like d'Alene
Maxwell who kill rapes and is
responsible for the rape of thousands of
minors is getting charged with this when
they admit in the freaking indictment
that she's a pedophile rapist right and
people get locked up for like 20 years
because they have like a jewel in their
pocket yeah they okay in the indictment
she's a pedophile and then they charge
her for like driving with a suspended
license yeah and that's why I'm saying
they're probably gonna let her post bail
and who knows what'll happen after that
I know you said she is a flight risk
maybe they'll be like oh well she went
to Israel she went to the UK oh she's
not here oh well we don't feel like the
port anchor right right where do they
find you where do they support you
Whitney Webb your you deserve support
you do a lot of research you you I would
be kept up at night I could never look
into this stuff with it with the depth
that you do thanks well I have a patreon
where you can support me in my upcoming
book on the Epstein scandal which we'll
have a lot more than what we talked
about today it's called one nation under
blackmail it will be out in a couple of
months great my run is Whitney Webb NPN
for you know for when I worked at the
Press news I don't currently work there
I have you can find me on Twitter that's
the only social media I'm really
using its underscore Whitney Webb and I
think that's really about it I have a
podcast that I don't because I do a lot
of other stuff right and I'm writing
this book and I write a lot of articles
I do have a podcast that are usually
just deep dives on articles or topics
I've dug into I'm called unlimited
hangout my second episode is going to be
coming out on this weekend it's going to
be you know a deep dive into Killeen the
Maxwells and the Maxwell siblings going
into a little more depth and they'll be
covered here so if you want to know
about this wild family you can look
forward to that it'll be available to
patrons first on this weekend and then
sometime next week I'll make it public
it's funny they're like that they're the
the massage Kardashian's yeah we won't
buy this that would have been there I
would yeah I would have titled the
episode that but I don't want to shoot
myself in the head four times
thank you so much you're the best we
appreciate it
stay safe will do thanks